yeah so main goal of my talk is to give
students and postdocs and younger
mathematicians the idea that macaulay 2
is something both rewarding to get into
and something that is possible to get
into and then there's some help
available and that there's some
professional opportunities available for
you so we have a website at McCauley
to.com and there are links to various
places and the first one I want to point
out is the link to the Journal of
software for algebra and geometry which
is a journal we started a few years to
provide a forum for publications having
to do with accomplishments in the area
of algorithm development and code
writing initially just for McCauley too
but now also for a gap in the singular
and Greg Smith and Amelia Taylor the
Managing Editors first and Greg Smith is
here so you can talk to him about that
but the idea of the journal is that the
contents page there have been six
volumes already and you can see that
there are very various articles here
that have been published and so far
every single article corresponds to some
code that somebody has written and
packaged together for others to use
along with documentation and the article
is a traditional mathematical Oregon
oval article written in five to seven
pages that explains what the code is
about what the code does how to use the
code and what their algorithms are
behind it and whether they're new and so
on and so if you go to that website
yourself you can click on
and click on one of the articles and
read the abstract and then download the
paper let's see oh yeah here's the PDF
file up here let's click on that to get
the PDF file and then also the source
code of the package is here but also in
addition to that all of the source code
that goes into all of these articles
becomes a permanent part of the McCawley
to distribution and so everybody who
downloads mccauley to gets all of the
packages that are described in these
articles so
what do I mean by package well Macaulay
too has some part of the built-in
software of it is devoted to organizing
software in some sort of documental unit
that we call a package and there are
examples of how to write these packages
and when I switch over to looking at
code I'll show you some of that and in
fact the packages are detailed here in
the download section there are these
various packages and there are the names
of them and the ones with the gold stars
are the ones that have been certified as
having been reviewed and corresponding
articles been accepted in the journal
and then if you click on one of those
packages you get to the documentation
page for the package and oh there should
be a gold star here the link is broken
but you get and I thought the background
should be in color - oh I think it's
missing the style that's the problem
yeah well you know with the release of
1.7 that happened a couple of weeks ago
I put Irie supplanted the old
documentation from 1.6 with a new
documentation for 1.7 so it looks like I
left something out but in any case this
one has been certified as having been
published and buying one of the journal
and it tells you which version was
published and then you know we keep the
thing working for you because it's part
of our source code distribution and it's
changes to Macaulay to happen we update
the thing so even if you haven't yet
published or you don't ever intend to
publish you can submit your package to
become a part of Macaulay - and I'll
show you a little bit about how to do
that with gift if you submit your
package to become part of Macaulay -
we'll maintain it keep it running and of
course you should include a test suite
so that we know whether your package is
continuing
so
but what about getting started with
Macauley - well there is a section here
called getting started and you can see
some interactive sessions you can see
some expositions how a new person -
McCauley - might get started these four
things portray it presents some of the
common basic modes of using McCauley -
and then if you have questions one of
the valuable things is our Google
discussion group where there are plenty
of people online we're willing to answer
your questions oh and there are three
pending messages to review for me I've
been getting emails about those also I
decided they were spam but yeah so there
will be no spam but you see their
various some questions asked and then
various number of replies have been
provided and so you can get help
so what else do I want to show well
actually the software libraries are sort
of interesting one of the aspects of
McCauley too is that it's some sort of
umbrella for the incorporation of a lot
of code written by others software
libraries and we call upon these
software libraries for various things
maybe not things that have to do with
every user but for example MPF R is the
package that does arbitrary precision
floating point arithmetic that's I think
Anto and I think you're actually using
that so that it's relevant for the
numerical code and so in some sense
being an umbrella like this Macaulay to
is able to provide lots of facilities
without us having to implement the
algorithms ourselves we just include
them and then events are advertised and
like this one is advertised
oh and then here's another great feature
which I didn't plan to mention which I
seen we have this is try it out and so
there are two ways to try it out you can
try out under the sage math cloud or you
can try our own cloud version or
McCallie - which was recently well
within the last couple of years
implemented so even if you haven't
succeeded in installing it on your
machine you can just go there and try it
out and your session will be maintained
for ever my core oh you feel you get
tired so at the moment it lasts for a
few days so it's a big machine with lots
of RAM so you can do real computations
there and you can consume a lot of CPU
time there without fear that anyone will
yell at you hopefully installing
macaulay - won't be much of a problem
there download section contains
installable compiled versions for
various operating systems now with we've
had a little bit of delay getting
various binary distributions of version
1.7 out but for version 1.6 there are
lots of different operating systems
available and for 1.7 so far there's
just a Mac OS 10 version in the blue -
14.04 version 64-bit but there others
will be there shortly
actually which which operating system
should I do next is it which one Debian
or a different version of Ubuntu any
preference
can I just stop is that enough already
windows all right the problem with
Windows is yeah the windows might take a
little bit of time or you man we ran
into a technical issue trying to do it
under the 64-bit cygwin which i think is
the only version that we'd I think
that's the version that's really
relevant for people now that computers
didn't have more than 2 gigabytes of RAM
and we ran into a technical problem with
part of the system software crashing
while trying to link our program
together so it's very sad but I know how
to work around it but it's going to take
some time but it'll run under cygwin not
natively under Windows but that should
be ok because cygwin gives you an
environment that's just like UNIX more
or less except that it's not as good all
right oh and then the documentation is
available on the website too so if you
are interested in by looking up the
documentation for some topic then Google
indexes this for us
you can you can find out how to do stuff
and see examples of doing it
so
so the source code for McCauley too is
visible it's free software the it's
licensed under the GNU Public License
it means anyone can copy it modify it
provided they satisfy certain conditions
about not keeping things secret and so
you can contribute to and if you find a
feature that needs to be added or you
want to add your own code you can do
that and so the way we suggest doing
that is by using the github repository
which is linked to here sometimes with
Mac OS 10 the browsers the browser stops
switching from an i-beam to a finger
when I'm on a link anyone know why that
is I usually just have to restart the
browser but I'm not going to take the
trouble to do that so here is our source
code repository at github in fact you
don't even have to download this source
if you want to browse the source code
and read it you can do that here over
the web so and then the readme file
tells you what macaulay 2 is and gives
you some instructions for how to get
started
and so in particular there's a link
right here for brief instructions about
how to use git that's from our wiki and
there's even an issue tracker where you
get to bug reports so suppose you find a
bug then you click on issues and you
compose an issue and you submit it and
we get notified by email that someone
has submitted a bug and take a look at
that and we schedule it to be dealt with
later
hopefully hopefully we deal with it
right away some of them can be dealt
with right away and and whenever I think
of something that I want to do I add an
issue so I don't forget to do it and
then the great thing about this bug
trackers that you can append annotations
like this has to be done by version 1.7
or you can add an annotation about who
gets to do it so my picture attached
there or Mike's picture says who's in
charge of doing it
and then there's the wiki I don't know
how much is there there's just that how
to use get thing but how to use get
thing is important because this is how
you're going to contribute software if
you get around to that so we had a fair
number of people earlier this morning
who claimed to have already saved some
software well just think how wonderful
would be if the software you saved were
documented and made available for other
people to use so the way you would do
that is by writing a package and
contributing it to the colleague too and
the way you would contribute to my
colleague too is by using this program
called get to and using github.com to
first of all create your own so-called
fork of our source code repository after
creating an account on github you're
allowed to do that and so in fact I
should show you my account setting in
so if I sign in and if I click on my
name then you see my page on github and
you see that I have some repositories of
my own
and one of my repositories is m2 and it
says it's been forked from McAuley to
slash m2 so what that means is that I
have a copy of that in my account and I
can freely make changes in updates to my
copy of that which is stored on the web
at the github.com website and when I'm
ready for those changes to the source
code to become part of the official
McAuley to distribution I can easily
notify the Macauley to developers of my
desire by issuing what a so called pull
request so the way it works is that you
might have might start out with an
identical copy of McCauley to source
code repository and mcculloch to
continue getting developed and change
and your copy you you will start
developing it and changing it and at a
certain point you want to merge or
changes in to our copy and so your issue
what's called a pull request and then we
get that and we look at your pull
request and we run it to see whether it
works and I want to make sure it works
because we don't want the source code
distribution to break and we put that in
and so that would be your first step of
course having the source code on the web
isn't so great from the point of view of
developing it so then what you want to
do is you want to download that source
code to your own machine so you can work
on it and that's what the get program
running on your machine is useful for if
it's not there you have to install it
but it's available everywhere
and then you do what's called cloning
the software you get a copy on your
machine you have all of our software and
you start changing it as you wish
including by adding your own files now
where would you add your own files to
add to McAuley - well at the top level
of McCauley - we see various files and
various directories or folders
if you click on em - that's where the
code is and their various sub
directories they're the only interesting
one now for us is the one called
McCauley - where the actual code of
McCauley - is and then I might also
mention that the library's subdirectory
has the code for those were actually
stubs for building and compiling the
code for those various library set I
mentioned to you before and then also
sub-modules has the code has some
different kind of hook for another way
of incorporating
a library anyway my colleague - is where
the source code is and you see what Mike
and I have written and what for example
what mike has written is a lot of what
mike has written is written in C++ in
the e directory and that's where the
basic algorithms for the governor bases
and matrices and resolutions are
implemented in the C++ language and then
in the m2 directory we actually have
implemented lots of mathematics in the
Macauley - user language that you saw
Mike typing and actually this is really
a cool feature about the Macauley 2
language that we have written so much of
our code for you in the same language
that you're going to get to use that the
language is powerful enough to add new
features to the system and so if you
want to add a feature to the system
which is just like a feature which is
already there or slightly different or
something that you should be able to do
that
are you gonna show them yeah I'm gonna
eventually I'm going to switch to
McAuley to actually show some code
but I wanted to point out first where
you would put your code if it's written
in the top-level McCauley 2 language you
would put it in the directory called
packages so here's where all the source
code for all those packages is and so
for example primary decomposition is
there oh that's in the directory
actually yeah well I should have clicked
on a file we have the directories and we
have the files so the file names end
with dot M - and then the directories
sometimes have the same name without the
dot M - and they come as a pair so the
top-level file will be the one with the
dot M - on the end like code F 3m - and
then if there's a directory with the
name code EPS that's where the other
files for the package will be located
and you can put anything there that you
want to have and so there's a little bit
of bureaucracy associated with I'm
having a package you have to give the
name of the package the version number
the date who the authors are a brief
description of what the package does
what are their packages are needed by
this package that's what package imports
is about and then this certification
block is inserted by us when you publish
your package in the form of an article
in the journal and then you give the
names of the functions or symbols that
you want the user to be able to use and
everything else is kept private so that
you don't clutter the namespace for the
user and then you implement your code
and so you put as much code in there as
you want and then you begin the
documentation section the purpose of
beginning the documentation section is
so that later on when your package is
loaded the documentation could be loaded
in this quick way and so if that
documentation is available loading of
this file will end at this point and
then the you can you have to document in
fact every one of your functions and so
and I think people have been a pretty
adept
getting things documented and when you
install the package using the Macauley
to de so-called installer it'll generate
the documentation from those
instructions in the form of web pages
that we've already clicked on and you'll
get an error message if you've forgot to
document something then as I mentioned
also you need to test that your package
work so that we can keep it working for
you and that's what all these test
strings are about so triple slash are
just the beginning of a text string and
the word test means the contents of this
string should be interpreted as as
commands later on that should be run to
make sure that the thing works then an
error will be generated if you program
it in such a way that an error would be
generated if it gave the wrong answer
and if it crashed of course an error
would be generated too so
so by the way documenting is doing all
the stuff even on your own package or on
your own work for your your research is
useful so that when you come back a few
months later you can actually make sure
that it works correctly you can look at
what it is that things we're supposed to
do takes a little bit extra time but
it's really a section Cayenne to that
yes collaborators yes
so I'm not going to actually run and he
get commands for you that's perhaps not
so important
what else did we want to show well on
the webpage
so
you see if that's true
I said everything I wanted yeah I think
I did all right so
I might suggested that I present at
least one little example of how one
tries to write code calling - so the
suggestion was that I show you how to
hold a tensor in unevaluated form so
this is this is a language issue you saw
that when Mike was typing it was it was
a a star star BB for example a a and B B
were matrices and it did the tensor
product but what if you wanted to read
it computed the tensor product and so
you know instead of a vector of length 4
and a vector of length 5 with a tensor
product symbol between them that you
could look at compactly you get a single
vector of length 20 but suppose you
wanted to hold them in the unevaluated
form so you could look at the component
tensors and then you wanted to evaluate
that later to see what it turns out to
be so this is a little programming
exercise so if you play around with my
colleague 2 or read some of those
getting started links that I pointed you
out you pretty soon find the factor
function which factors integers for you
and it returns a product and that's a
product and unevaluated form and you
should mention what's happening on the
second output line every time you type
in input line the prompt begins with I
and then there are usually or often
there are two outputs both begin with O
for output and one has an equal sign one
has a colon the equal sign says what the
value is equal to and the colon says
what type of thing the value has so this
thing that came out is an expression of
class product so we'll get into that in
a second
but let's just peek inside and see what
we see what we see is that there's the
word product which has already been
advertised to be the class of the thing
and then there are some numbers and
actually those are not exactly numbers 2
squared for example is it also an
unaffiliated form but we're interested
in just products now we're going to
think of them as tensor products well it
turns out if you read the documentation
you can find that for product it's
really a type of list and so you can
make a product from a list and there's
how you make one from scratch new
product from a list and then you
displays like that so the it's really
just a list together with an indication
in its class about how to display it
I want to give you the feeling that you
can do this too you can invent new
classes of object and you can invent new
mechanisms for displaying them I won't
go into details too much about how to do
that though but suppose we make a ring
and we make a free module over the ring
and then we take oh I should show what
m1 m2 and m3 are maybe I won't need that
chair but it can stay here you can stay
here let's put it on the stage that
would be really cool oh that's a lot
better it's in the right height for a
podium suddenly so Emma's a free module
it's art of the four and the subscript
picks out one of the generators so it
indexing as Mike says starts with zero
and there so we get these various things
and these things are if you look at the
: output line these are things of class
are to the floor so these are vectors in
the or elements of the free module
if we make a product from three vectors
well it looks sort of cool just right
there we have a displayed product in
unevaluated form we're thinking of it as
the tensor product but at least it
displays with the three components and
you know I could multiply that by two
and it would be two times that and I
could add that to
so that and it keeps building up these
formal expressions for us a nun
evaluated form so but what about getting
the value of sign Lily well with
factoring when after you factor a number
if you read the documentation you can
read it very carefully within eagle eye
you will discern that there's a function
called value that releases the thing and
gets the thing evaluated back as out and
computes the value and so that's what we
want to implement next we want to get
that to work
does it work already let's try it no it
didn't work already so don't be afraid
to make things not work you can always
debug them there's a built-in debugger
and hopefully the error messages say
something informative so when you see an
error message is this the temptation to
do something else but actually read the
error message and see whether it tells
you something and in this case it says
no method for binary operator star
applied to an object so it has that one
vector times another vector well of
course vector times vector doesn't
normally make sense in fact as you saw
from Mike's demonstration it's the
double star that makes tensor product
not the single star but I think we can
make use of this thing being undefined
by defining multiplication of two
vectors to be tensor product no no it's
an undefined operation so far we're not
going to break something in the system
that depends on this operation being
undefined so we can just bravely define
a multiplication operation for vectors
but now how does defining a
multiplication operation for vectors
work how does defining operations work
in this programming language well when
you have a vector like m1 I mentioned
before that everything has a class and
the class is displayed on that colon
output line well there's a function
called class which tells you what the
class is so we can use that as a way of
examining things the class as advertised
as
are to the floor but the reason I want
to take a look at that a little more
closely is to explain how inheritance
works in the ecology language it's some
sort of it's sort of like an
object-oriented programming language
where you can have classes being
subclasses of other classes and the
algorithms or methods that apply to the
larger class will also apply to the
subclasses unless they're explicitly
overridden and so to get to the larger
class we have a function called parent
in this case the parent of art of the
four is vector let's try a few others
what's the parent of
kick you to the 11 it's also vector so
every element in a module is first of
class that module that module is a type
it has instances and then the parent
class the larger class is just called
vector and so there are some things that
are implemented for vectors and some
things that might be implemented for
just certain types of modules but we
might as well implement tensor product
of vectors to work for any two vectors
in any two modules so there's no reason
to think that our job now is to
implement product of two vectors in r2
the four because then we won't have done
it for art of the five our job now
really is to implement multiplication
for two vectors so if you use the
function methods
you can get a list of all the methods
that apply to vectors and there's
certain number of them the first one is
tensor product it has two stars so that
would be the how you make a tensor
product of two vectors and then there
are other ones and you can get the
source code of those two if you want to
but I won't show how to do that well but
we can get the help so turns out that in
that list the symbols you can't just
type them in again because if you type
star star tries to be an operator
between two things
so typing symbol allows you to get the
symbol as an abstract entity and then
you can get the help for star star so
it's the tensor product and this help is
the same thing you would see on the web
version of the documentation it's
available in line while running the
program with the help command in fact if
you forget how to do it
or if you need help generally you could
just type help and it gives you some
advice about what to do if you're just
getting started so type help so um star
star is the tensor product operation for
vectors we saw that for matrices in
Mike's talk he wasn't using vectors and
then as I was advertising before does
the computation out but we want to leave
it an unevaluated form that's the point
of our exercise so here's what we do we
if you find a new method this is the way
you define a new method you mentioned a
type types are the sorts of things that
are valid as classes of other objects in
the system this will be the method for
multiplying a vector times a vector and
you write a colon equal always this is a
different use of the colon equal then
Mike explained this morning and then you
put a function that does the job and the
job is to just do the star star W which
is what we wanted to do in the
first place
so now if we make one of these formal
products unevaluated and take the value
well then it just works
so value now works because we've added
this method for multiplication oh yeah
so I think that's um the end of my
software demo now if you wanted to
change the display would you change the
net command yeah yeah so you can change
the way it displays so you might well I
keep pressing something get rid of this
junk so the display you look sort of
ugly in some sense what's happening here
is that the slash and the vertical bars
and the slash in the leftmost column are
my simulation of what a left parenthesis
looks like in ASCII art form and then
you see some ASCII art right parenthesis
also and then those parenthesized things
are adjacent to each other but maybe it
would be nicer if inst you had no
parenthesis and you just put a double
star between the vectors suppose that's
your assignment well then you could do
that there's you would override the
method for creating this ASCII art so
the function in Macaulay 2 for taking a
mathematical object and creating an
ASCII art two-dimensional representation
of it is called net the idea is that a
string is a horizontal sequence of
letters and the net is a two-dimensional
sequence of letters and it's sort of
optimized so that the rows can have
different lengths and the thing can
float above or below the base line like
a box in tech and so you can play around
with that here the base line for this
net is always in the output it's always
put at the location of the equal sign
but you know you do see super scripts
coming out and like if you type x
squared and then the to the X comes out
on the base line and two is above that
shows you that these output boxes are
like boxes and tap
the coefficient came in with products
and sums of products I do what exactly
like have a formal sum of classes of
products and I want to say what you know
one to five coefficient of that formal
summoner's oh because these are tensors
and they have triple indices but we just
gave a very compact way to express them
and are you are you thinking there
should be a way of taking one of these
unevaluated things and picking out oh
yeah so then what you would want to do
for example is well first of all you
might be dissatisfied with this thing
being an expression of class product
because that doesn't say it's a product
of matrices and what you're just talking
about is something that would only apply
to products of matrices I should have
said vectors you're talking about
something that would only apply to
products of vectors x squared Y
coefficient is in this product so then
maybe we don't have to introduce a new
class to hide our code but what you
would then you could write code where
you would define a certain function
which accepts an argument of type
product and then when it's an argument
of type product you remember that it's
really basically just a list and you can
use the standard features of Macaulay to
language to extract the elements of the
list one at a time and then let's say
we're talking about three factors in the
product and then you want to say the ijk
coefficient where I and J and K are to
be interpreted in the three factors and
so you would just loop through the list
taking out the ithe coefficient from the
ice matrix and then
multiplying those together and we turn
that sum but then I mean if you want to
use the feature where I mentioned before
you could multiply one of these formal
expressions by a scalar or then maybe
add various pure tensors then you would
have to loop over such things and so if
you have a sum for example
then what does that look like internally
first of all it's an expression of class
some rather than an expression of class
product but again an expression all
these expressions are really just types
of lists this is just a list to go
through the label that you should add
the terms and so if you have a sum and
you're computing the ijk coefficient you
would just loop through here and get
that i JK coefficient and then add all
the results similarly for scalar
multiple and then maybe you would call
it a day after doing that
but my part of the presentation is
actually done are there any other
questions you only inherited classes of
a class yeah so for example actually I
forget where the show structure takes
arguments but we have this function
called show structure looks like give it
an argument like vector I have no idea
whether this will work oh yeah oh this
oh this gives the parents a vector so no
we don't have it the other way but you
could but if you type that same command
without an argument then you get the
display of the entire tree of parents
and you can just find your thing here
are the types of expressions for example
and maybe we see it our there's our R
yeah so there if we look at ring element
every element of every particularly
turns out to more generally be a ring
element and so if we make some more
rings
I do that show structure command again I
think we'll see some more interesting
things up there yeah ring element so
there are three rings every element of
which is also a ring element we did not
organize that in any sort of
programmable way but at least you can
get the output visually let's see if you
look at the top of this tree
you see that at the very top is the type
called Thing Thing is the unique type
whose parent is itself and the idea
there is that everything in the system
is a thing and there's nothing about
things oh you could define a function to
act on things I mean there are functions
that take arguments of type thing
meaning they'll know you can do anything
with them for example anything could be
a subscript so you just say I'm gonna
this function I'm writing could accept
something of class thing but then at the
the children rather than the
grandchildren of thing would be the most
basic datatypes in the system then basic
list would be an example of one and the
expressions of type sum and product as
well as this things with the braces that
Mike was showing you are examples of
basic lists and anyway you can have fun
browsing this stuff and see what all
this stuff is and then here we see some
mathematics actually coming in with
various types of ring like basic best
practices for programming in the color -
for instance like you defined three
rings because I've used my calling to
you before I could guess that the last
one that you defined is the one that
it's gonna think I'm using but then this
is a like this is a common pitfall that
I noticed that I a mistake they make
this mistake often where the switch
rings and try to do some computation and
there's no method for the variables I'm
using because it was in a previous
string can you just like say a few like
why use parentheses not parentheses
maybe like how to make sure that you're
working in the ring that you want to be
working and some of these comes alright
I'll say a few words and we can follow
up on that if I don't say completely
enough one thing about McCauley too is
that there is no notion of something
like the ring in which you are currently
working the concept just doesn't exist
that was true McCauley won there was a
ring in which you're currently working
but in McCauley too we've you know I
created these various rings but were
they they had variables T and U and X
and then R was I forget what our was
what was our R had a through E now in
this case the three rings have variable
names that don't overlap with each other
so if you type a then you'll get an
element of art if you type T you'll get
an element of that one that mentioned
team and what was the other one X yeah
the other one is X so these rings
haven't interfered with each other at
all and the reason is that they're names
of their variables are disjoint sets so
one good practice if you want to avoid
getting confused is to not use rings
with overlapping names of variables
however suppose you really really want
to do that
then you might here let's say that a is
the ring on the previous line say a is
the class of X so that's our polynomial
ring qqx and let's say B is going to be
Q Q of X Y and now if we say X plus y
then we'll get something in B which is
as expected and if we say X we're not
going to get something in a even though
that was the only thing in X that what
happened here is that the symbol whose
name is X got assigned a value and the
value was an element of that ring if you
want to go back to using the other ring
then there's this way of going back and
then if you type X you get an element of
a and if you type X plus y you get
expected pair to have a method and
that's probably the sort of thing you
had been running into where you have
rings with overlapping names of
variables so the I can I think all I can
recommend is that if you're writing
packaged functions that create that
crate rings for temporary use then you
try to strive to keep have those rings
use local variables as their names of
their variables so that it doesn't
interfere with what else you're doing
and hide that and we can teach you how
to do that and if really you want all
those variables there and you want to
use them all you should just have
disjoint sets or you should just use the
use command to recall the particular
ring you want to work with so what
usually happens to me is that I do is
closing and then the parables are
naturally the same that's the names are
the same yeah that's right and so there
you can't really you don't really have
the option of using disjoint sets of
variables but you could use the use
command to switch back and forth between
the ring and its quotient but the youth
command did was looked at the ring a
looked at the names of its variables and
assigned those symbols in the language
values which are the corresponding
elements of the ring so if we would use
B right now then the X variable would
now be instantiated from the ring beep
all right that's really of course
another thing you could do is to just
refer to the generators of the ring
anonymously by their number
can you talk about parentheses what's
the question about parentheses you often
don't use parentheses but then sometimes
you have a function with two arguments
and maybe you do use parentheses and
then when you're finding a function so
are you saying that f equals x arrow
something like um X plus 3 and G equals
parentheses X arrow X plus 5 so you got
your question X comma Y goes to you know
so these are various ways of defining
functions and so there is a slight
difference between what you see on line
53 and what you see on line 54 the
difference is only that a gene will
insist on getting just one argument all
right
the previous gene let's bring back the
previous gene
beause I try that with two arguments
then this has expected one argument but
God - whereas the F is really a little
bit too specific for the purpose of this
demo I will accept the two arguments and
given the error later on so the only
point of having an argument without
parentheses around it is if you want to
be able to accept the sequence as the
argument for example because you want to
deal with a variable number of arguments
it looks like it's accepting three fours
old as as the X like the list three
fours that's right
X is the sequence and but you don't know
the length in advance it could be length
100 and then you might want to do
something with every member of the
sequence so here the parentheses are
completely irrelevant they're only
relevant when defining the function
elsewhere in expressions that get
evaluated the parentheses you use solely
for grouping there's no yeah maybe
that's what the deal is that you're
really questioning but just out in
Macaulay too when you have a function
applied to an argument the parentheses
are optional in fact what's happening in
Macaulay to us that is parsed in the
following way you have an expression and
you have an expression and you just have
a space in between and so space is one
of the basic operators in McCulloch -
and you can install methods for it you
can decide that here I'll illustrate
that so 3 for the default method for
when there's a function a space and a
thing is to apply the function to the
thing there is no default method for
what to do when you have an integer a
space and an integer so you could feel
free to define it to be something you
want you could define it to multiply for
example and you wouldn't have to type
all those pesky stars anymore
so which order these things evaluated
them because left to right
questions have died down I can let my
cab the last eight minutes and you can
show you something about your foot okay
so before you were doing it I was
thinking that Phoebe you would like to
define the new product class instead
like the tensor product classes define
yeah in fact that's what my first
version of the demo I had oh no I didn't
have a new tensor product well any way
you could do that so how do you define a
new class this is actually an important
point so let me touch upon it you've
seen that we have these things called
classes and you've seen that there seem
to be a lot of them and so we must have
a way of making them well you can make
them too so for example suppose you want
tensor product of vectors to be a class
and you want to do something with it so
what you can do is you can say tensor
products should be a new type of basic
list
and then you could say new as her
product from a pair of vectors
and then now you're now you're starting
to get going
so you have a new type of list and you
can start doing something with it
now the reason I took basic lists
instead of list is because I don't want
to inherit all the methods that apply
the list for example one of the methods
that applies to lists is that a number
of times the list is the list of
products where you multiply the number
of times every entry of the list and if
I had said tensor product equals new
type of list then if you would type two
times here let's illustrate that two
times that thing is there's no method
that's good we're going to implement
that that's what you have to implement
but if I had said
list instead of basic list basic list by
the way is the parent of list then if I
do all this stuff again it has a very
sad consequence so you have to be
careful about the inheritance but yes
you can make new types new classes and
you can make them print out the way you
like this might be the way to play
around with yes but now so the idea of
showing you about expressions was that
we already do have this whole facility
the objects of class expression which
are designed to hold expressions and
unevaluated form and in fact that
facility is used extensively in
assembling things for printing yeah
that's a oh that's the in fact a better
idea if we want it to be part of that
and maybe there's a particular type of
an expression it should inherit I think
I'm done suggestion is really an
excellent one because the way expression
diff'ent is defined is expression is
just a new type of basic list that's how
we defined expression in the system and
so now if we do it this way and do show
structure and somewhere up there we will
see our new tensor there it is tensor
product has now been added to the bottom
of the list of all the things of whose
parent is expression and so whatever
applies to expression will get applied
to that and actually this is really this
is really a very good idea to test them
if we where did I make this thing oh
yeah we have to go back now let's make
it one of these and now let's see what
happens with two times it what happened
there is that because we inherited from
expression we got the facility for
expressions inherited and the facility
for expressions means that a number of
times an expression is converted to an
expression in unevaluated form in this
case
to product and if we would peek into it
not so good
Oh also not so good yes up to four you
see that if you peek it's a product so
it's really a very good suggestion
yes so you can now give me the braces
having normal brackets and parentheses
yes so if you just type 1 plus 2 times 3
and this will obviously hopefully not be
evaluated from left to right but this
the multiplication of magician come
first and then you know of course
there's there's parsing presidents
that's right if the 2 times 3 is
evaluated after the 1 so ok or it
doesn't matter so you switch it it
doesn't matter so that's that's my point
so can use this almost as a [ __ ] I mean
you can define your own operators for
example space we can expiation define
what the space pricing precedence of
operators is all predefined and it's
documented and let's see where is I
think it's documented and there's
something you could reach that's he
maybe operators or something like that
oh there we go precedence of operators
yeah so here is here is the table that
shows what parsing precedents the
various operators have that's pretty
fine
there's no way to adjust it space is an
operator you say yeah let's move down a
bit there it is
that was get ripped off you will like
transpose Emma here square one times in
Duratec
underscore to knowing what that's going
to do yeah so maybe print out this table
and then you'll see how everything works
yes one could use parentheses but how
does one know well because you don't
really want to clutter the page for the
reader of your code with all sorts of
unnecessary press parentheses so you
really want to eliminate every single
parenthesis that not absolutely needed
time is coming to a close I we have only
two seconds left